this uh this Dahmer thing is huge
because as it is very hot it's this guy
who's just taking advantage of people he
is bringing them home he's getting it
done
um it is hot didn't he do them a little
bit of a favor though they're in
Milwaukee it's the deal it's a good way
to exit Milwaukee and the deal is
everybody is kink shaming him because we
live in a CIS hat nightmare but this is
a guy who early on his Kinks were like
taking pigs home from uh biology and
dissecting them in his room and that
evolved into people and uh but his cool
you know the the thing does kind of like
Dahmer's dad is suing Netflix for
glorifying his son
this is true yeah because it is cool
when you look at the thing when you're
watching it you're like Dahmer's kind of
hot yeah he's kind of cool he does some
things we don't agree with but overall
who doesn't who doesn't overall he's a
likable
hot dude who's like get just on on the
Journey of like getting his confidence
and and people want to be him for
Halloween this is how much it succeeded
people want to be Dahmer for Halloween
and now Amazon has stopped uh selling
the Dahmer costumes because Simone biles
among others the gymnast who couldn't
perform because she was sad
um she the one who dropped out of the
Olympics she is like telling everybody
don't you dare come showing up as Dahmer
because he did kill a lot of young men
and boys of color yeah but not you know
the person showing up is Dahmer didn't
that's always lost it's just a costume
party yeah it's uh that's always lost on
people yeah I mean you know what's the
big deal do you remember when Dahmer got
popped because you you've been around
yeah I'm 80. so when when Dahmer got
popped do you remember this being a big
deal was this a media circus it was a
media circus yeah we love serial killers
it's almost
um unfortunate that they've been kind of
put out of business by DNA and yeah and
the surveillance State the uh you know
well serial killers now just gone parlor
they go on parlors no they never get to
the actual hard work of stalking and
killing yeah they just pop off well we
have I think they mutated into School
shooters oh interesting Incarnation is
that's it your theory yeah because you
know it's like uh it's a star that we
make them Stars right so it's like you
know someone's gonna wanna walk down
that red carpet that's right of blood
and it's somebody who can get the you
know it's kind of an immediate result
immediate overnight as opposed to a
serial killer who has to go through this
process for a very very long time you
don't have to do Conan you don't have to
do a half hour right you go straight to
fame yeah what are the True Crime
podcasts going to do because we know all
these sick [ __ ] who love they just
love the idea of people getting stalked
and killed yeah and they talk about it
endlessly and they make the families
relive all this trauma my favorite
murder uh Georgia and Karen all the time
they won't stop even when the families
ask them to stop they're like please we
don't need this they do kind of exactly
what Alex Jones did which is they get
everybody revved up to like crack let's
crack the Cold Case right
um what are they gonna talk about now
that serial killers are done how are
they going to manipulate people's trauma
and grief for uh ad sales they're just
gonna have to go to war crimes podcasts
that might be interesting yeah there's a
little war crimes podcast but that's not
cool because that's not sexy enough and
when I watch Dahmer what's so
interesting maybe the ladies feel left
out maybe because he was only focusing
on gays subconsciously the ladies are
like upset well also some of the ladies
are like so what this is being a woman
every day you know because that's the
new attitude like they're like getting
eaten chased by cannibals that's being a
woman 24th chef
that's what it's like to be a woman oh
finally oh is it disturbing that
accountable is drugging and eating you
how about you try being a woman for
literally 15 minutes try being a woman
that has an idea in a meaning full of
men for literally 15 minutes it is
essentially having your liver eaten by a
cannibal in Milwaukee that is also part
of some of the attitude I see now yeah
no it's not a bit it's not such a huge
deal it's tough It's really tough it is
disturbing to watch though because he
brings these guys up to his thing and he
drugs them and they're like trying to
get out and they're stumbling around I
mean you know it's a little bit of a
Halloween episode here I have the Great
Pumpkin on and you're dressed like some
type of costume but this is your real
thing you know I don't know what this is
Danny Zuko I don't know what you're
doing or what the point of it is but
whatever it is it's called Arrested
Development
I should have on khakis and no idea
Merrell Shoes yeah and glasses yeah you
you live in this beautiful thing you
have this beautiful family and you're
out here dressed like I don't even know
you got money on your street or
something you're collecting numbers but
he some people meet a very bad end in
America yeah and that's what I thought
about watching Dahmer I said some people
meet a very very bad and and I don't
mean like some of our friends where
they're just accused of rape after a
pretty good career
I mean like a bad end like they go out
one night and it just doesn't it they
think it goes gonna go one way and it
goes the other way yeah but it's rare I
mean you know if you get selected there
is some sort of uh you should sort of
feel special a little bit you were
selected it's a rare selection yes it's
a small club that gets eaten by Jeffrey
Dahmer good job Netflix it's very
difficult to hate him here yeah I'm
telling you you watch other things and
it's easy to hate the person there's
something tough here because you're like
he's experiencing so many things that
are running through his head you can
hate him yeah they portrayed him as sort
of a lonely a loner his mom was mean to
him he's figuring it out yeah a
coming-of-age story that's what it feels
like feels like a coming to age it's
like a fun gay coming-of-age story he's
got his shirt off all the time and
occasionally he eats someone's kidney
it's not it's sexy it's kind of fun it's
like Netflix was like let's make
something hot yeah it and let's make
something fun it's like a young adult
why a movie with cannibalism well it's
so unlike like the entertainment
industry in Hollywood to make something
like this
well they look back at podcasting one
day as this insane like I wonder how
they'll look back at all this like well
they make a Dahmer movie but about this
like well they just look back and go
there was a point in our history where
people just talk for hours and hours and
hours endlessly with no facts really
nothing to back any of it up at best
case they guessed about things worst
case they completely made it up uh they
were everybody from comedians to [ __ ]
journalists to writers to just Common
Street people and they would just get on
the microphone and just pontificate
about things knowing nothing about them
you wonder if at some point they look
back on this and they go that was
damaresque
like do they do they look back on this
and go like there's endless endless
hours of these [ __ ] idiots talk like
will they make a movie about this like
called like podcast where it's just like
people years from now are so fed up with
this medium it's become so cringe to
them like the idea of like guys and
headphones sitting in front of a
microphone makes people as sick as
Dahmer eating someone